vous avez fait ce concours vous arrivez
en finale vous avez pas gagné vous êtes
arrivés en finale mais tous les
présidents des grands labels vous ont
vous ont appelé et Michael Jackson
alors on vous appelle Anastasia la jeune
Tina Turner blanche
on m'appelle effectivement
[Musique]
ça marche ça marchait énormément en
France donnait vendu un million
d'exemplaires dans le monde entier en
match combien vous allez vendu dans le
monde entier
Laurent pas laisse tomber à peu près
alors vous dites la plupart de ces
chansons étaient composées rapidement et
spontanément et interprété pareil parce
que lorsque dur Belinda parce que
lorsque je chante un morceau trop
longtemps ou trop de fois il devient
artificiel
dire c'est que c'est à partir du studio
expérience sépare quand je suis sur
scène je peux le faire
chanter en Tove tous les jours mais dans
un studio vous êtes en train de créer et
si je reste trop longtemps je me sens
pas naturel je me sens pas aussi vivante
que sur scène et je m'ennuie quand vous
devez être énervé ça doit être terrible
avec vous non je vous vois là vous êtes
sympa mais quand vous devez être énervé
je vais donner la fessée
[Rires]
et en fait quand elle dit qu'elle peut
pas chanter trop trop de fois en studio
ça me fait penser à Djoko qui lui aussi
préféré chanter en live et voilà et
c'est peut-être le privilège des grandes
voix en fait alors Elton John Elton John
il vous adore tout le monde nous adore
Melton John aussi alors évidemment de
chanter avec lui au Madison Square
Garden et après il a mis un genou à
terre et comme quoi il appelle
l'habitude de Elton John il vous a
embrassé le nombril c'est marrant il
fait pas
parce qu'il sait pas le pauvre en même
temps mais bon
très rare que je me retrouve médusé sans
pouvoir parler c'est le seul homme vous
imaginez Elton John le seul qui puisse
me garder silencieuse
donc
il m'a un petit peu choqué sur ce coup
alors vous avez une voix bon c'est une
voix black mais vous n'êtes pas vous
n'êtes pas noir vous n'êtes pas beaucoup
de sang noir pas du tout même
je chante vraiment du fond de mon cœur
je chante avec passion avec de là mais
il semble que les gens veulent dire que
c'est black mais c'est vraiment la façon
dont je chante c'est tout à fait
authentique c'est ce qui me sort alors
c'était difficile pour vous parce que
quand vous êtes arrivé sur le marché les
gens ne savaient pas dans quelle
catégorie vous placez parce que vous
avez une personnalité une voix très
étrange
c'était dur pour moi parce que je vous
en voulais tellement et à chaque fois
que j'essayais de m'avancer travailler
avec quelqu'un il ne savait même pas
quoi faire avec une perle une voix comme
la mienne mon physique et au lieu de me
laisser chanter comme je le fais et
c'est accepter par le public ils ont
décidé de ne rien faire ou alors vous
savez j'ai fait des tas de choses du
country
différents types de musique le pop la
dance et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
très bien alors peut-être vous étiez
noir dans une autre vie je sais pas en
tous les cas vous appelez Anastasia
phone nuke
vous l'avez un peu raccourci pendant la
guerre parce que c'est vrai que pendant
la guerre Funker que ça devait faire un
drôle d'effet vous avez été levé à
Chicago votre père était chanteur dans
les boîtes quelle boîte dans des boîtes
il était chanteur son père je vais te
dire où il était chanteur dans des
boîtes de la côte Est et dans des hôtels
des Cats îles
bien alors le père chantait donc dans
les quatre cils et sur la côte
elle chantait également dans des
comédies musicales et je restais
beaucoup avec elle dans les théâtres les
coulisses beaucoup plus qu'avec mon père
quand vous étiez jeune votre père est
parti
si Monsieur nuker nous regarde il peut
toujours nous téléphoner non votre mère
a chanté à Broadway dans les comédies
musicales à Broadway et vous vous allez
en fait vous découvrez bon vous allez
dans une dans une école dans une école
de pour apprendre mais c'est surtout
dans les boîtes à l'âge de 18 ans vous
découvrez la house music hein et c'est
là que vous avez décidé de devenir
chanteuse non
je faisais de la danse voilà sur la
chaîne MTV il y a eu un show comme ça
qui s'appelle MTV club MTV et alors il y
a des filles des go-go girls comme ça
qui dansent si vous étiez là-dedans vous
et là vous avez rencontré celle qui est
devenue votre votre agent on peut dire
Lisa braodet qui vous avez fait une
espèce de graine de stars qui s'appelle
de Kate MTV c'est comme ça qu'on vous a
découvert vous avez fait ce concours
vous arrivez en finale vous avez pas
gagné vous êtes arrivés dans le final
mais tous les présidents des grands
labels vous ont vous ont appelé et
Michael Jackson
parce que bah oui Michael Jackson c'est
la première fois qu'il voyait quelqu'un
comme lui c'est-à-dire une blanche avec
une voix de noir donc celle-là
complètement
[Rires]
bien il vous a appelé Michael Jackson
je savais à quelle heure il allait
m'appeler c'était tout à fait après-midi
il m'a expliqué au cours de cet appel
qu'il pensait que j'avais beaucoup de
talents en tant que chanteuse et que
j'étais un artiste à l'échelle mondiale
qui pouvait devenir
tout à fait
et que je ne vais pas abandonner quoi
que ce soit même si j'étais refusé par
certaines maisons donc il a été vraiment
gentil avec moi
il était ce que je pensais de lui tout à
fait gentil l'avantage avec Michael
Jackson c'est que c'était pas pour des
raisons sexuelles qui vous appelez en
même temps donc c'était ça qui était
bien c'était uniquement professionnel
c'est l'avantage mais il lui a donné son
numéro de téléphone ultra secret c'est
vrai
alors je suis content de vous voir parce
que vous j'avais lu avant de vous
rencontrer vous déclarez souvent dans la
presse que physiquement vous vous
attirez pas vous aimez pas tellement
physiquement et quand on vous voit il y
a pas de raison de passer mais je
comprends pas ça c'est quoi cette
histoire Anastasia
j'étais vraiment vous savez le vilain
petit cadeau
vieillissant mûrissant les choses se
sont un peu mises en place
et j'ai vraiment des bons maquilleurs
vraiment vous avez Anastasia a rencontré
son jules vous avez été standardiste à
l'époque et c'était le jour d'Halloween
et elle était grimée en sorcière avec
des couettes comme ça énormes des dents
noires des angles crochus le mec vient
dans le bureau il la voit après je la
rappelle non mais c'est vrai et oui
qu'est-ce qu'on peut dire si vous avez
aimé dans cette situation là et déguisé
comme ça après vous pouvez faire tout ce
que vous voulez alors vous êtes séparés
et puis maintenant vous êtes de nouveau
ensemble ça va
ouais
il est revenu vers vous c'est lui qui
est revenu ou c'est vous
c'était tout à fait mutuel c'était notre
karma notre destin j'imagine
[Musique]
vous savez il est on ne bouge pas
pendant le jingle
on ne bouge pas pendant le jingle bonne
réponse de Thierry AR
bien on va faire une interview croyance
est-ce que vous croyez en vous
est-ce que vous croyez en Dieu
quelque chose de spirituel un esprit une
good
est-ce que vous croyez au diable
est-ce que vous croyez en Elton
est-ce que vous croyez en George W Bush
pourquoi vous êtes en France est-ce que
vous croyez Elvis Presley vraiment mort
est-ce que
qui en esprit et l'esprit pour moi il
vit toujours
même quand vous
noter
est-ce que vous croyez au sexe sans
amour non non pas du tout
je préfère à ce moment passé mais vous
pouvez vous en passer
je suis abstinente depuis longtemps
ah ouais ouais oh là là
vous avez quitté les États-Unis
est-ce que vous croyez
à la masturbation
est-ce que vous croyez à la régénération
des cellules de l'épiderme du visage par
des crèmes anti-rides
parce que tu ne vas bien
que oui est-ce que vous croyez au Père
Noël
non il est normal
est-ce que vous croyez à Jean-Hugues
Noël
c'est plus important si vous croyez à
Jean-Luc Noël d'abord je vais remercier
Belinda
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et ensuite je vais vous laisser partir
parce que je sais que voilà vous
repartez toute seule en plus qui est
très vous avez beaucoup de mérite
j'aimerais bien rester mais il faut
vraiment que je prenne un vol demain
matin très tôt vers l'Allemagne
et le tatouage le tatoue bien sûr
comme si vous ne saviez pas
c'est quoi comme tatouage bon les
cadresur vous êtes prêts pour le
tatouage bye bye Anastasia
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu